winners of this year's Queens a queen
elizabeth fries for engineering will be
announced in London this afternoon so
ordered every two years but aims to
raise the profile of the secretary
inspire young people to work in the
industry and with us now who is with us
now let's tell you one of the judges is
Professor Brian Cox Brian a very good
morning to you what we think of
Engineering if you're a young person
considering what kind of career you're
going to forge your head in engineering
isn't necessarily the first thing that
comes to mind and we can talk about the
reasons for that is they want to pay as
it status is it simply too hard work
what's going on I think it's just a lack
of information engineering occasionally
can conjure up images of steam engines
and Brunel you know that it has in some
sense an old fat image completely wrong
engineering is really the creation of
everything that we think of and use in
our society so it can be software
engineering it can be there the software
that goes inside mobile phones acquitted
mobile phones themselves it can be
spacecraft manufacture I mean did you
know that one of the biggest growth
industries of the UK is the manufacturer
of small satellites were well leading at
that and sometimes when I go into
schools i talk about science engineering
and I say well it would any of you like
a job building spacecraft then a lot of
hands go up in fact our spacecraft
industry is is that there are vacancies
available that this is the key I think
to the Queen Elizabeth prize and we need
1.25 million more trained people in
science and engineering in five years
time in order to fill the demand
currently in our economy which is a good
thing because it means our economy is
growing in high tech areas that we want
but it's also a concern because there
are 1.25 million unfilled baked
vacancies will be somewhere 600,000
unfilled vacant vacancies and you can
sort of sort this PR can't you and say
ok so not just about the big pistons and
the grimy stuff it's sexy it's a much
broader tableau than you think but at
the end of the day when you've got your
essential economics that dismal of the
most dismal of sciences tell us that if
you've got a shortage of something the
best way of curing that is to pay more
it really comes down to pay
well I these jobs a well-paid jobs there
than there what the government call
knowledge intensive services and
industry jobs so the best paid jobs in
our economy they're also put aside
finance let's say but even in finances
people with stem degrees that are going
into that area but put inside that so
these are the areas that we know will
grow our economy these are the areas
that Britain can compete in high skilled
highly educated workforce so the
challenge really mr. is to get into the
schools and then through to the
university's first of all to infuse
those children to say these are the
areas if you're doing physics maths
chemistry engineering mathematics the
STEM subjects then there are vacancies
available highly paid vacancies and
secondly to make sure that we invest in
education all the way through from
schools and through so universities to
enable those that the workforce of the
future to be trained and made available
to industry and say one more thing that
we live of course in a globalised world
and so industries big multinational
industries who employ in this
high-skilled sector they move to where
the educated workforce exists so we're
fortunate with the QE prize that
although it's an international prize
we've got it in Britain and that means
that we can use it to promote these
areas so those industries will be
attracted to this country and pay the
wages that you suggest you see why you
want to track near encourage young
people to go into the sciences I've got
you know an eldest daughter who's doing
three sciences she hopes were available
but I don't see how a prize and that's
what we're talking about a prize will
necessarily see help people like her see
engineering is more sexy there's a sort
of slight logic air gap there fill it
for as if you can well the if you look
at the Nobel prizes for example which
are based in Sweden what they do is they
shine a light a media lies if you'd like
on areas of research the nobel prize for
physics was won a couple of years ago by
a colleague of mine two colleagues of
mine at manchester university for the
discovery of graphene a new form of
carbon so in the same way the Queen
Elizabeth prize is a Nobel Prize for
engineering so it highlights particular
areas of work particular areas of
achievement the outline by the way is
that we award the Quinlan's prize to
things that have all
ready made a significant benefit
globally to humanity that's that the
raison d'etre of the prize if you like
so the idea is it shined a light is
information it's about saying this is
what engineering is it's not just steam
engines or you know the engineering of
old it is now basically the creation the
design and creation of everything we
take for granted in our technological
society so you want more pic young
people to embrace engineering I suppose
the demographic cake is only so big
though isn't it if you have more young
people choosing engineering that's fewer
young people who are going into the
humanities and the creative industries
and sitting the same seat that you're in
today tomorrow we have somebody from
advertising or the art saying you know
come here when you young people to go
into the arts don't do boring
engineering do some humanities subject
because that's where it's needed I don't
think we're at that point yet so that at
the moment we're at the point where our
economy is based half of it is based on
what we call knowledge intensive
services industry which includes as you
say the creative industries but also
science and engineering half of it the
government all parties is agreement on
this want to grow that piece of the cake
why because that's the way that advanced
economies like ours compete globally in
the future so there's plenty of slack to
be taken up with certainly not at the
point where there's competition for high
skilled labor between the humanities and
the sciences and engineering that's not
where we are we're at the point where we
need to build a more educated workforce
we've got a long way to go yet and what
you say to those again those young
people who are sold on your message they
bought your message okay Brian Cox has
persuaded me engineering sexy okay but
they have grave misgivings about their
maths I just don't think they've got the
maths to be a good engineer and they've
got a feeling and it may be a feeling
that's rooted in some sound logic that
actually if they're not good at it it's
not something they couldn't necessarily
work on and learn you're either good at
maths or you're not good at math and
engineering is open to you that's fine
if you're not you're always going to
struggle it's a central misconception
this I think about mathematics I myself
didn't think I was good enough at
mathematics of school to go on to do
physics at University and actually I
discovered quite late in life
that mathematics is something your eyes
the language of science and engineering
but it's something that can comes to us
through practice I often make the
analogy of playing a piano you know one
virtually no one sits down in front of
the piano and can play it you have to
practice and learn to same with
mathematics and I would say that that it
becomes more enjoyable and easier the
more you practice and so if you don't
think you're good at it it is most
likely because you haven't just put that
extra bit of work in science and
engineering need a bit of work maths
needs a bit of work but it's not
something I think very very few people
are naturally brilliant mathematicians
you don't need to be a naturally
brilliant mathematician you just need to
put the practice in and then these
careers will open up in front of you I'm
just one final thought really we were
talking just exclusively the load about
young people but there may be people
listening to you a little bit older
perhaps not sure they did the right
thing you have to school or after
University backed the wrong horse
they're unhappy and their job think
about a career change into engineering
how easy is it for them and it's not as
easy as it is that the age of 18 is the
honest answer I regret that actually but
there are schemes and government are
rightly looking at this how do you
retrain a workforce who I should say
we're not talking about 1.25 million
phd's here we're talking about 1.25
million skilled people all the way
through from apprenticeships all the way
through to researchers so there are
opportunities at every at every level
whether you like to be to be more
practical or you like to be more
theoretical so the training I think the
opportunities are opening up but you're
right to highlight that I think we need
to do more and again just to finish that
I think that's one of the important
things about the QE prize it's not only
about inspiring children so that
inspiring parents at about inspiring
policymakers in government and shine
your light on this necessary area of the
economy Brian Cox is one of the judges
on the Queen Elizabeth engineering award
we presume means queenless with a second
I guess Brian engineering it's queer
love you sought you thanks a lot thanks